[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir kennen das tram preis jenen mann der
die gratwanderung nicht nur liebt soll
sie auch beherrscht wie kaum ein anderer
politiker regel sind für ihn dass da um
ihre grenzen auszutesten oder auch mal
zu überschreiten
viele seiner gegner erhalten ihn
deswegen für erratische oder gar
verrückt und gucken dann dumm aus der
wäsche
weil sie ihm gerade deswegen
unterschätzt haben und schon lange bevor
er präsident wurde dass donald trump
damit im laufe der jahre das bild eines
erfolgreichen selfmade unternehmer ist
aufgebaut eine art könig midas der in
der lage ist alles in gold zu verwandeln
was er anfasst eine unschlagbare
geschäftsmann eben die leibhaftige
verkörperung des amerikanischen traums
tatsächlich war genau dies eines seine
hauptargumente während seiner
präsidentschaftskandidatur immer wieder
versprach er dass er seine erfolgreichen
und bewährten management fähigkeiten ins
openoffice einbringen würde dass er das
ganze land mit den gleichen geschickten
würde mit dem er sein firmenimperium
immer gefühlt hatte
[Musik]
ende september 2020 jeder
veröffentlichte die new york times die
wohl glücklichste untersuchung der
steuererklärungen jobs darin geht es
auch um seine mehr als 500 firmen und
einen zeitraum über 20 jahre demnach
zahlte presse strump trotz des immensen
vermögens im jahr 2017 nur 750 dollar an
steuern
weitere 57 dollar im jahr 2016 und in 10
der vorangegangenen 15 jahres hatte er
nichts nun nada und jetzt wagt du dich
vielleicht wie soll das gehen
da ist doch milliardär und gibt immer
damit an dass er unmengen an geld
verdient am ende dieses videos wirst du
genau verstehen wie diese grillen
steuerzahlungen zustande kommt ja es
gibt dafür ziemlich logische erklärungen
aber das ist noch nicht alles die
untersuchung der new york times zeigt
nämlich auch wie james finanzen unter
der massiven verschuldung und unter den
schlechten ergebnissen seiner
firmengruppe leiden eigentlich könnte
trank viel viel reicher sein als er
tatsächlich ist wenn er besser
wirtschaften würde und all das trotz der
tatsache dass songs firmen seit seinem
antritt als präsident viele aufträge und
kunden gewonnen haben die sich über
diese geschäftsbeziehungen einfluss auf
dem staat sichern wollen
interessengruppen lobbyisten oder
ausländische regierungen mieten sich oft
parteien um die gunst seiner familie zu
gewinnen denn natürlich möchte ich
wieder gerne in der nähe des präsidenten
der usa sein
jeder möchte ihm einen gefallen tun und
im fall von trump ist dies so einfach
wie nie zuvor
man muss einfach geschäfte mit einem
seiner unternehmen machen
da wäre zum beispiel der fall des clips
mar lago dessen einnahmen dank der
kandidatur von trump in die höhe
geschnellt sind die einnahmen aus den
mitgliedsbeiträgen des klubs haben sich
im jahr 2016 pc sagt und das bevor im
januar 2017 mitgliedsbeiträge verdoppelt
wurden auf diese weise konnte der
präsident zwischen 2015 und 2018
zusätzliche 26 millionen dollar ein
und natürlich gibt es noch viele weitere
beispiele unternehmen nämlich deren
geschäfte von der regierung abhängen wie
walgreens pharmaceuticals oder
engineering company haben räume in
trance immobilien bis zum anschlag
gerichtet und zwar ausgerechnet genau
dann wenn sie mal wieder was von der
regierung brauchte sogar ausländische
regierungen wie die türkei hat die
veranstaltung entfernt immobilien ab
wenn sie wollen das ist zwischen den
beiden ländern besser läuft gut aber
ehrlich sind haben wir uns an all diese
dinge ja bereits gewöhnt so verdächtig
umstritten kontrovers sie seien die new
york times behauptet jedoch dies sei nur
ein kleiner teil von krems zwielichtig
chaotischer geschäft historie
in diesem video wollen wir dies alles
mal beleuchten denn egal ob mannschaft
nun mag oder nicht es lohnt sich allemal
darüber bescheid zu wissen woher sein
vermögen stammt und was hinter den
kulissen seines business imperiums so
alles erlebt also schauen wir uns
zunächst an
wie alles begann wie ist das trump an
seinen milliarden vermögen gekommen
der ursprung des imperiums wir alle
kennen donald trump als denjenigen der
sich selbst als selfmade milliardär als
eine ultimative geldmaschine preist aber
wie viel ist davon war ein job ist er so
schon fest von einem
immobilienentwickler aus new york city
da ein riesiges vermögen angehäuft hat
das inflationsbereinigte wäre es heute
rund eine milliarde dollar wert im alter
von nur drei jahren verdiente donald
trump bereits 200.000 dollar pro jahr
das ist richtig bedacht war er bereits
millionär mit 16 jahren war er der
glückliche miteigentümer eines
mehrfamilienhauses mit 52 wohneinheiten
als er das college abschluss erhielt er
von seinem vater eine million dollar pro
jahr wobei die zahlungen jedes jahr
sogar noch zunahmen als tramp möchte
seinen sohn donald zu einem manager
miteigentümer banker und berater
innerhalb des familienunternehmens mit
dem wahrscheinlichen ziel einen teil
seines vermögens über gehälter an ihn zu
transferieren oder so zu vermeiden
schenkungssteuer dafür zahlen zu müssen
er gewährte ihm auch ein darlehen nach
dem anderen
und viele dieser darlehen mussten nie
zurückgezahlt werden außerdem übertrug
er doppelt aktien und eigentum unter dem
wert fragt investierte viel geld in das
unternehmen und er wird zahlt sogar
seinen persönlichen chauffeur
[Musik]
insgesamt wird geschätzt dass dort schon
auf diese weise mindestens 413 millionen
dollar von seinem vater erhalten hat das
ist schon eine ganze stange geld illegal
ist daran jedoch nichts im grunde hat
genau das getan was alle reichen
menschen tun
sie suchen schlupflöcher um ihren
kindern so viel ihres vermögens wie
möglich zukommen zu lassen ohne dass der
fiskus in form von erbschafts oder
schenkungssteuer zuschlägt und genauso
unfair ist zu sagen das gesamte vermögen
des stroms stammt von seinem vater denn
forscher dieses auf heute drei bis vier
milliarden dollar
aber natürlich mit der list geld ging
vieles leichter denn mit alten vermögen
dass sein vater ihn gehabt konnten und
damit wirken und kredit aufnehmen
hunderte von millionen dollar mit diesen
krediten brauchte er dann sein imperium
auf immobilien wie den jumper das plaza
hotel dass mara lago spekulative
aktienkäufe eine fußballmannschaft die
casinos in atlantic city und sogar seine
eigene fluggesellschaft die tram shuttle
incorporated ende der 1980 er jahre
schien trump der kind zu sein ein könig
allerdings der bis zum hals in schulden
steckte wir reden hier von mehr als 3,4
milliarden dollar das meiste davon shop
anleihen für die eher hohe zinsen zahlen
musste
dies führte dazu dass viele von uns
unternehmen bald in konkurs gingen so
dass die investoren aktionäre und
partner die tramps pini vertraut hatten
am ende etwa 1,5 milliarden dollar
verloren
jobs selbst hat diese pleite
erstaunlicherweise relativ unbeschadet
überstanden
denn er hatte seine eigene haftung durch
komplexe finanzstrukturen geschickt
begrenzt er rappelte sich wieder auf und
baute die sogenannte tromp corporation
auf so und wie hat zwar dort dann als
unternehmer abgeschnitten ist er jetzt
zu jeder money maschinen geworden als
die er sich immer präsentiert
[Musik]
showstar oder unternehmer wenn es eine
sache gab die dann als junkie zum ruhm
verhalf dann war ist die reality show
the apprentice eine show in der die
teilnehmer um die entwicklung des besten
projekts innerhalb einer firma oder
immobilie konkurrenten tram wurde dort
als der amerikanischen kugel und vor
allem knallharter verhandlungspartner
präsentiert der beste der besten einer
der jeden die hinbekommt und damit sehr
viel geld verdient aber wir alle wissen
was really tivi ist show ist show und
hat nicht viel mit der realität zu tun
eine tatsache über die tramps et ganz
offen spricht ich spiele mit den
fantasien der menschen die menschen
wollen glauben dass etwas das größte
wertvollste unspektakulär ist ich nenne
das die übertreibung für unersetzlich
es ist eine unschuldige form der
übertreibung und eine sehr wirksame form
der werbung als die show lieferte tromp
im echten geschäftsleben alles andere
als eine goldene zeit nach mehreren
kursen in seinem kerngeschäft schiene
sein imperium zu zerfallen
wir liefen in den büros home und sounds
erschließende möbel wir sagen überall
wie ein imperium zerbröselt unsere
aufgabe bestand darin es im fernsehen
aber wie das genaue gegenteil aussehen
zu lassen und sie schaffen es während es
wurde ein riesiger erfolg einer mit dem
die hohe landesweite popularität donald
trumps begründet wurde
[Musik]
aber john verdiente durch die show auch
prächtig insgesamt rund 420 millionen
dollar direkt mit seiner teilnahme ganz
197 millionen und indirekt weitere 230
millionen dollar
weil nun alle möglichen marken mit ihm
und seinem namen werbung machen wollten
und trump lehnte praktisch keines dieser
angebote hôtel pizzas kekse stakes wodka
brettspiele kölnisch wasser waschmittel
unterwäsche er gab seinen namen sogar
für bettmatratzen her
für schlappe 15 millionen dollar denn
wer wollte nicht schon immer auf einer
tram pendelt nicht wahr
allerdings übertrieb ist lang mit dem
verkauf seines namens dann auch so
bewahrte zum beispiel ein keramik system
verkaufte millionärs kurse und gründete
sogar eine art universität die am ende
angesichts zahlreicher betrugsvorwürfe
und einer klage der new yorker
generalstaatsanwaltschaft schließen
musste brand musste deswegen sogar 25
millionen dollar entschädigung
ähnliches geschah übrigens später auch
mit der tram foundation die nach einer
missbrauchs klage der new yorker
generalstaatsanwältin barbara anna wird
aufgelöst werden musste ein weiterer
bekannter skandal war der von bach
kaliforniens name einen luxus
appartement komplex schmücken sollte am
ende fehlten aber irgendwie 32 millionen
dollar und es gab viele betrugsvorwürfe
gegen die baufirma und sogar trump
selbst
trank wird in mexiko wegen steuerbetrugs
bei gescheitertem immobilienprojekt
verklagt das motto lautet eben wo
gehobelt wird da fallen späne und trump
ist schon ein ordentlicher hobler denn
das geld aus der show sitzt er wieder
als hebel um sich noch mehr geld zu
leihen und damit wieder eine menge
immobilien zu erwerben
diesmal protest und golfplätze
[Musik]
das problem war aber dass nicht alles in
den 1990 er jahren geschah uns die
charts firmen damit keine richtigen
gewinne erwirtschaften konnten zum
beispiel haben sich allein aus dem
geschäft mit den golfplätzen seit dem
jahr 2000 mehr als 300 millionen dollar
an verlusten angehäuft das im jahr 2016
eröffnete trump hotel in washington auch
schon 75 millionen dollar verluste zu
seinen wenigen profitabel
vermögenswerten gehören der trump tower
und das mahlanlage die bilanzen der
anderen unternehmen sehen eher mau aus
unterm strich sieht es also ganz danach
aus dass trump eine großartige
kommunikator ist er weiß wie kein
anderer wie er sein publikum erreicht
und er hat diese fähigkeit genutzt um
mit seinem image viel geld zu verdienen
aber als investor scheint er keine so
glückliche hand zu haben hätte er für
das ganze geld das ihm sein vater
gegeben hat ganz einfach einen für
jedermann zugänglichen indexfonds auf
den s p 500 am aktienmarkt kauft nichts
getan hätte sein vermögen bei
amtsantritt 11 bis 13 milliarden dollar
betragen können also rund viermal so
viel als durch seine eigenen geschäfte
und seine zeit in atlantic city
charakterisiert wohl am besten den
unternehmer jamal so schauen sie aus
dieser geschichte mal genauer an
[Musik]
die katastrophe in atlantic city
es gab eine zeit in dirt jump die
glücksspielindustrie winslet xtb
dominierte er besaß drei der größten
kassel kompletten der stadt darunter das
taj mahal das im april 1990 als größtes
casino der welt eröffnet wurde samt
finanzierte das alles meist mit hilfe
von hoch verzinsten anleihen mit
zinssätzen von bis zu 14 prozent der
schuldenstand des champions betrug
damals 3,4 milliarden dollar davon
entfielen 1,3 milliarden auf die drei
kasinos in atlantic city und diese
schuldenlast wurde sehr schnell zum
problem und bereits ein jahr später im
jahr 91 musste das taj mahal konkurs
anmelden
wenige monate später auch die beiden
anderen von kontrollierten casinos dass
john glaser und das trump kassel sonntag
ist nun 50 prozent seiner anteile an
gläubiger abzugeben als gegenleistung
für niedrigere zinssätze und einen
zahlungsaufschub
das löste schien damit abgewendet und
die casinos drücken weiter betrieben
werden aber so ganz verstanden die
probleme nicht
[Musik]
im jahr 1995 drohte erneut der bankrott
hatte eine idee er gründete ein neues
unternehmen in welches das trump blase
eingebracht wurde und durch eine
kapitalerhöhung an die börse gehen das
unternehmen nahm von 9 aktionären 140
millionen dollar auf und nutzt diese um
weitere 145 millionen dollar durch die
emission von hochzinsanleihen es zu
einem zinssatz von 15,5 prozent zu
beschaffen und steckte diese insgesamt
300 millionen dollar jedoch nicht in die
erweiterung des casino geschäfts legte
damit kredite für die app persönlich
gewirkt hatte aber nur wenige jahre
später brauchst du das unternehmen
wieder frisches kapital
vor dem hintergrund großspurige
ankündigungen die sich später als
irreführend erwiesen wurde eine erneute
kapitalerhöhung über den aktienmarkt und
auch eine erneute emission von
hochzinsanleihen durchgeführt diesmal
wurden 1,1 milliarden dollar beschafft
mit diesem geld das hatte das
börsennotierte unternehmen noch mehr
kredite ab für die tram persönlich
gebürgt hatte obwohl diese bessere
kondition aufwiesen als die neun
hochzinsanleihen außerdem kaufte diese
firma auch die beiden anderen von cramm
kontrollierten casinos zu einem preis
den viele aktionäre damals für überhöhte
ebenso mietete sie sehr teure büros im
zschopauer und obwohl es den unternehmen
immer schlechter lebensalter ist dran
weiterhin großzügig etwas zwei millionen
dollar pro jahr für die verwendung des
namens trump plus ein üppiges gehalt als
vorstandsvorsitzender
unterm strich verdiente die firma nie
richtig geld sie investierte nicht genug
in die hotels und casinos und verlor so
nach und nach marktanteile
denn ihr angebot konnte mit der
konkurrenz nicht mehr mithalten auf
diese weise verloren das unternehmen bis
zum jahr 2080 prozent seines börsenwerts
das trump hotel und casino resort musste
wie der konkurs anmelden zuerst 2004 und
dann nochmal 2009 insgesamt verloren
aktionäre und gläubiger dadurch mehr als
1,5 milliarden dollar und zur gleichen
zeit wurde wie e trend ist ins leben
gerufen wo trump sich als erfolgreicher
unternehmer präsentierte der wie kein
anderer wusste wie man geschäfte macht
ja hätte er sich doch von anfang an nur
im showgeschäft verdeckt vielen anlegern
und auch ihn selbst wäre viel ärger und
viele verlust erspart geblieben so und
wartest du sicher schon ganz gespannt
auf die erklärung warum kommt in den
letzten jahren so gut wie keine
ins all musste nun wir wollen sie
natürlich nicht vorenthalten also
aufgepasst
[Musik]
warum sonst schon keine steuern
in den zehn der letzten 17 jahre hat die
kooperation keine bundes einkommensteuer
gezahlt und in den jahren 2016 und 17
zahlte sie nur 750 dollar pro jahr
und die frage ist wie um alles in der
welt kann das sein und dafür gibt es
zwei gründe erstens haben viele seiner
unternehmen wie wir bereits gesehen
haben keine gewinner sondern nur verlust
erwirtschaftet und wenn man kein geld
verdient muss man eben auch keine
steuern bezahlen und zwar just two
stroke einfach das was alle millionäre
ton er hat verdammt gute steuerberater
angeheuert und die nutzen auch das
allerletzte steuerschlupfloch aus auch
wenn dies manchmal rest kann sein mag
beispielsweise beantragte trump im jahr
2010 bei den steuerbehörden eine
rückerstattung in höhe von 70 millionen
dollar für gemeldete verluste aus seinen
geschäften in atlantic city
die rückerstattung wurde ausgezahlt ist
bestehen jedoch zweifel ob dieser antrag
auch wirklich begründet war
das finanzamt prüft ihn zusammen mit dem
kongressausschuss möglicherweise muss
das geld plus zinsen zurückzahlen oder
auch nicht ein schwebendes verfahren
john's steuerberater sind auch nicht
zimperlich was das absetzen von ausgaben
angeht ihren charakter eher persönlicher
denn geschäftlicher natur zu sein
scheint zum beispiel flugzeuge rüttgers
seinen willen sogar ein friseur
praktisch alles was kommt in rechnung
gestellt wird ist steuerlich abzugsfähig
zb ein riesiges anwesen namens seven
springs 80 hektar grundstück mit einem
fast 2000 quadratmeter großen herrenhaus
und dreist wenn die nun offizielle
betrachten die chance des lebens prinz
als anlagevermögen so dass die
gesellschaft zusätzlich zu den
hypothekenzahlungen alle ausgaben
abzieht die entstehen und zwar bis zum
letzten cent und da ist das auswechseln
einer glühbirne pro jahr macht das 2
millionen dollar an steuereinsparungen
gleichzeitig nutzen die transsib seven
springs jedoch auch privat zum wohnen
auch bei anwalts rechnungen vermischtes
schon gerne privates und geschäftliches
tja wer blickt da schon durch und am
ende wird das alles natürlich alles
geschäftsaufgabe abgezogen und so kommen
hunderte von posten an steuerabzügen
zustande mit deren hilfe trump in den
letzten jahrzehnten kaum steuern zahlen
musste
das alles hat die new york times jetzt
transparent veröffentlicht so dass sich
jeder selbst ein bild von donald trumps
finanzen machen kann und was immer man
von trump halten macht eine sache muss
man ihm schon auf jeden fall zugestehen
hund ist er schon
oder was denkst du dass wir immer deine
meinung in den kommentarbereich zu
diesem video
wir hoffen dass er dieses video gefallen
hat falls ja gibt uns bitte auch einen
daumen hoch und unterstützt uns in die
nuss mit deinen freunden
und vergiss nicht dass wir jede woche
neue videos hochladen werden also
verpasst kann ist unsere updates
abonniere unseren kanal blick auch auf
das kindeswohl um rechtzeitig
benachrichtigt zu werden was gut und bis
zum nächsten mal
[Musik]